obviamente uma página todas ea todos
honrem o adversário hoje participa do
evento não vejo o importante é tratar de
temas que são absolutamente inovadores e
importantes para a nossa sociedade
eu vou falar um pouco sobre a minha
trajetória acadêmica e profissional
rapidamente
eu sou formado em direito foi bom e me
formei em 1999 e fiz mestrado e
doutorado na área das ciências criminais
da criminologia e tenham estudado esse
tema da violência e do sistema de
justiça criminal
portanto desde a minha graduação então o
meu foco de de observação de análise de
angústia indigitação é o tema da
violência que que afeta todos nós a toda
nossa sociedade ea forma como nós
reagimos a essa violência sobretudo
através dos mecanismos de controle
social que são protagonizados pelo
estado é um sistema de justiça criminal
então esse sempre foi o meu foco de
estudo aí minha em horizonte
profissional de atuação no sentido de de
compreender as opressões as dores não é
tanto das vítimas conta dos dos
encarcerados e das vítimas do próprio
sistema de justiça penal então eu vou
fazer uma pequena um pequeno panorama do
drama e da situação que nós estamos
enfrentando na atualidade para oferecer
aquilo que eu acredito que seria uma um
caminho possível para a gente enfrentar
essa essa realidade tão cruel que nós
estamos atravessando vivemos num
momentos difíceis tanto no mundo com
conta no país momento de descrença
política de crises profundas né
econômicas éticas é e sociais na que
levam à a explosão de de violência de
todas as ordens
então a minha a minha preocupação tem
sido exatamente isso seja de que modo
essas crises dessa situação econômica
política e nós estamos vivenciando afeta
as nossas relações sociais produzem
essas explosões de violência
o brasil é um dos países onde há um
número de pessoas encarceradas no
planeta nós temos a terceira maior
população carcerária do mundo
estamos atrás dos estados unidos em
primeiro lugar e da china em segundo e
também temos é um dos maiores índices de
violência letal ou seja o país que mais
se morre gente no dia a dia na polícia
no brasil por exemplo mata seis pessoas
por dia
nenhuma outra polícia do mundo produz
uma letalidade tão assustadora quanto a
nós e ao mesmo tempo é a polícia que
mais morre também então a gente vive de
fato um momento de guerra ou seja o
brasil atravessa índices de violência
letal que são comparáveis às papaiz que
estão vivendo situações de guerra
declarada e o brasil não está vivendo
uma situação de guerra declarada
então é uma guerra sobretudo contra a
meu ver a pobreza e aos pobres é uma
ocupação militarizada do território da
pobreza da pobreza em nome de uma guerra
às drogas sobretudo ela historicamente
sistema penal sempre atuou na
criminalização ea repressão das classes
subalternas de muito mais do que punir
crimes
o sistema penal sempre atuou de modo a
reprimir as ilegalidades populares não
sistema penal sempre na sua história
isso é um só um dado do da tecnologia e
da história do sistema de justiça penal
de que historicamente o sistema penal
sempre foi um mecanismo de produção de
dor e de violência contra os cortes
subalternas no início da modernidade
a função da prisão não era punir crimes
era adestrada uma mão de obra necessária
para o surgimento do capitalismo
industrial é que era a fábrica não há
prisão nasce como uma espécie de irmã
siamesa da fábrica
já aqueles indivíduos que vinham do
campo da decadência da ordem feudal para
as grandes cidades e não se ajustavam o
trabalho da fábrica e um ocupar as
prisões são os no início as casas de
correção as casas para pobres a work
house na inglaterra
nas casas de lavoura na itália os
hospitais gerais na frança então são
mecanismos foram instituições
construídas
a tornar os corpos dóceis tornar os
corpos adestrados por trabalho na
fábrica partida da revolução industrial
não ser uma final nunca foi um mecanismo
para punir crimes nem existiu
historicamente para é garantir a gestão
diferencial das ilegalidades que
significa isso
veja eu torna visível algumas
ilegalidades para esconder outras que
começam a parecer recentemente no caso
brasileiro as grandes fraudes políticas
e econômicas dos grandes fraudadores da
nação agora eventualmente aparecem como
sendo objeto da captura do sistema de
justiça penal mas fora também se chama
penal nunca se viu a isso jamais vai
servir tanto é que as penas aplicadas a
esse andar de cima da sociedade são
sempre penas muito brandas mas são
sempre penas risíveis comparado a todo o
sofrimento ea todo o índice os níveis de
violência que som é atingir as classes
nas classes populares então
historicamente tem uma penal sempre
serviu isso a gerir diferencialmente as
ilegalidades a tornar visível algumas
ilegalidades reprimir algumas
ilegalidades para esconder outras e
garantir a impunidade de outras
ilegalidades ea gente ingenuamente
acredita que o sistema penal é de fato
aquilo que vai vingar
a sociedade vai defender a sociedade
os criminosos então a gente já parte de
uma premissa que o equivocada de que
existe uma divisão na sociedade entre
homens bombons e criminosos tecnologia
mostra que todos nós praticamos delitos
eventualmente cotidianamente muitas
vezes só que os nossos deles eles não
dão cadeia ou eles não são passíveis de
punição porque são exatamente esses
delitos que não são objecto preferencial
da perseguição criminal seja por isso
que as cadeias brasileiras estão
abarrotadas de pobres sobretudo jovens
negros e pobres não têm uma penal
brasileiro sobretudo ele é
essencialmente racista e classista e
um dos principais protagonistas dessa
violência letal e dessa seletividade
inerente ao sistema penal é a chamada
guerra às drogas
a gente precisa urgentemente debater
isso no brasil é que a legalização das
drogas é um a meu ver um dos caminhos
fundamentais para a gente superar esses
níveis de letalidade que nós estamos
atravessando a guerra às drogas é uma
fraude histórica política científica
ela não tem nenhuma fundamentação
científica
a seleção das drogas que são
consideradas listas das listas por
exemplo não obedece a critérios
científicos elas essa guerra às drogas
ela nasceu sobretudo para perseguir
minorias nos estados unidos no início do
século 20
ela tem um fundamento moral de associar
usuários de drogas a degenerados morais
ela tem um fundamento político
ideológico que era as substâncias que
são perseguidas eram as substâncias
típica das minorias consideradas
perigosas nos estados unidos é uma coisa
associada aos mexicanos
a cocaína associada aos negros
op associado aos chineses o álcool no
início do século 20 com a lei seca
cansaço estava associado aos imigrantes
europeus então a guerra às drogas
representou historicamente essa fraude
política científica ideológica e serviu
de álibi pra esse genocídio compulsivo
que nós produzimos no brasil sobretudo
da nossa juventude negra e pobre uma
guerra às drogas é hoje o carro chefe da
produção social da violência que nós
estamos vivendo
cerca de mais de 30% da população
carcerária brasileira está presa por
tráfico de drogas
mais de 200 mil homens estão presos no
brasil por tráfico de drogas o tráfico
de drogas é esse varejo da droga não são
políticos carregando seus helicópteros
meia tonelada de cocaína não são o
varejo da droga que essa juventude da
periferia dos morros negra e pobre que
encontra na venda de drogas numa fonte
de renda mais directamente acessível em
um país de excluídos no país de uma
corrupção sistêmica generalizada e
portanto é essa violência social que a
criminalização das drogas produz tanto
pela disputa pelos mercados
não é pelas grandes quanto da
operacionalidade letal e violenta que o
sistema penal direciona sobre essas
comunidades então nós estamos vivendo
hoje no brasil aqui mesmo no espírito
santo mas o rio de janeiro parece ser o
grande paradigma com as upps
essas ocupações militarizadas do
território da pobreza em nome dessa
guerra santa contra as drogas que na
verdade representa uma guerra contra os
pobres
é exatamente isso que representa guerra
às drogas essa fraude política
científica histórica como me referir que
na verdade se traduz numa guerra contra
a pobreza contra os pobres sobretudo uma
criminalização da miséria e sistema
penal de brasileiro faz criminalizar
sistematicamente a miséria nas costas
subalternas criando historicamente
inimigos para justificar toda e se esse
nível de letalidade então nós inventamos
os demônios para poder justificar as
nossas inquisições nós já no início do
século 20 foi o comunista o sindicalista
com o estado novo a partir da década de
2030 os imigrantes europeus que chegavam
no brasil procurando novas perspectivas
de trabalho encontravam níveis de
exploração do trabalho próximo dos
escravos e começava a se organizar em
sindicatos um sistema de justiça penal
naquela época foi direcionado a combater
o sindicalismo anarquismo comunismo as
doutrinas consideradas subversivas na
ditadura civil militar e 64 inimigo
passa a ser novamente a ameaça comunista
ea partir da redemocratização um fim da
guerra fria
a gente não tem mais essa é a ameaça
comunista para combater necessariamente
a gente precisa criar novos inimigos
estados unidos inventaram o terrorismo a
guerra ao terror e nós inventamos a
guerra ao traficante traficante aparece
então como essa figura é a encarnação do
mal que ameaça a saúde ea sanidade nossa
sociedade que a gente aceita
passivamente o seu extermínio jornal
nacional quer dizer sim mataram hoje
mais dez traficantes na favela da maré
nenhuma indignação
nós continuamos continuam
a nossa vida é passível mente sem nenhum
tipo de reação porque associar a a esse
corpo matar viveu na classe de
traficantes justifica a eliminação já
menos 10 graças a deus né
então de fato a nossa sociedade abençoa
a nossa sociedade aceita passivamente
'extermínio' compulsivo porque acredita
que há de fato uma luta do bem contra o
mal
então o que eu proponho basicamente
diante de tudo que eu tenho vivenciado
tanto na minha vida acadêmica quanto o
pesquisador quanto na minha vida prática
um advogado como militante dos direitos
humanos na oab ac do espírito santo e na
minhas andanças também por outros países
sempre pesquisando e tentando entender o
funcionamento do sistema de justiça
penal e da violência é exatamente um
primeiro momento a legalização das
drogas e no segundo momento perceber que
o sistema penal ele é um instrumento que
produz muito mais violência dor e
sofrimento do que a violência que ele
pretende combater são historicamente o
sistema de justiça penal moderno ele
nasce no século 13 com o confisco do
conflito o que significa isso com o
surgimento dos estados soberanos
um rei ele confiscou conflito das das
vítimas concretas da sociedade em nome
do exercício do seu poder soberano
o estado moderno se caracteriza
exatamente por isso pela centralização e
pela unificação do poder pelo monopólio
da violência só eu soberano possa
aplicar a lei possa produzir a lei
aplicar a lei
então há uma substituição das vítimas
reais por vítimas absolutamente
abstratas e seria lei a sociedade o
estado
o soberano então as vítimas reais elas
desaparecem da competitividade e se
coloca no lugar uma vítima absolutamente
abstrata uma vítima em real
então por exemplo se ele furta um uma
botija de gás da minha casa o meu
celular o que quer que seja eu quiser
perdoá lo
o sistema de justiça penal não deixe
porque ainda assim ele vai ser
processado julgado
condenado conforme as leis porque a
gente entende do ponto de vista
científico teórico e político de que
esse crime não é um crime contra minha
pessoa de carne e osso
é um crime contra toda a sociedade é um
crime contra o soberano contra um estado
soberano não perdoa ninguém então eu
posso perdoá lo não quero que ele vá
para a prisão não quero isso eu não
acredito que o sistema vai
responsabilizar mas ainda assim o
promotor vai oferecer a acusação contra
ele o juiz vai julgá lo e ele vai ser
condenada por isso e as prisões
brasileiras estão abarrotadas de pessoas
que furtaram ganha ganha duas três peças
fizeram um dia como picanha na vida
ninguém eo também a gente não quer só
comida a gente quer comida diversão e
arte
a gente não quer só comida então essas
vítimas eu sugiro que vocês assistam a
um documentário chamado bagatela é que
mostra é o cotidiano do funcionamento da
justiça penal no brasil para mostrar
exatamente isso
é grande o volume de pessoas que estão
presas absolutamente por nada né por
pequenos furtos por pequenas pequenos
delitos e essa é a grande massa é de
pessoas que estão presas no brasil chega
cerca de 80% da população carcerária
está presa por tráfico e crimes
patrimoniais
os homicídios menção à violência
absolutamente é que nos incomoda de fato
essa violência letal ela não é um objeto
preferencial do nosso sistema de justiça
penal cerca de oito por cento dos
homicídios no brasil conseguem ser
apurados e gente consegue esclarecer na
qual quem é o autor desse desse delito
então esse é o drama que nós vivemos e
uma das temáticas que eu tenha estudado
e me dedicado é exatamente a chamada
justiça restaurativa que significa
exatamente a gente devolver o
protagonismo do sistema de justiça penal
as vítimas porque o sistema penal não se
preocupa e nunca se preocupou com as
vítimas a sua função foi a pagar
vítima e transformar o sistema de
justiça penal num sistema político de
dominação de classe
nós crimes patrimoniais eles são muito
mais graves do que os dos crimes contra
a vida os crimes contra a integridade
física por exemplo as penas são muito
mais altas
o crime de tráfico de drogas que é
vender fornecer ainda que gratuitamente
uma pequena quantidade de droga para
alguém é muito mais grave do que você
aleja uma pessoa por exemplo
então o que justifica isso é exatamente
aquilo que que tá não dito ou não dito
o sistema penal declara que a sua função
é proteger a sociedade é combater o
crime e se a função declarada do sistema
aquilo que ele diz que ele promete que o
que ele esconde exatamente que por trás
desse discurso ele sustenta uma
dominação no exercício dessa dominação
de classe uma sociedade absolutamente
injusta e desigual como a nossa
então a justiça restaurativa ela se
propõe a estabelecer mecanismos muito
mais de mediação dos conflitos do que de
repressão e de punição mas sobretudo
quando a vítima quer dialogar com aquele
que que agrediu ou seja isso é um algo
que está na nossa vida que a gente pode
levar a nossa vida pessoal seja a
vingança seria um dos fundamentos da
pena nós queremos fazer sofrer a quem
nos fez sofrer só que a vingança pura e
simples ela não é justiça
a vingança ou a justiça não é sinônimo
de vingança não são expressões
equivalente então na minha prática
cotidiana também vi isso pessoas que
perderam suas formas de seus parentes
seus entes queridos e viram os os
algozes serem condenados a 20 e 25 anos
de prisão e não ficaram satisfeitos
porque a punição ela não traz de volta o
nosso o nosso ente querido que foi
perdida se a vingança por si só ela não
nos satisfaz ela não apaga seja
importadora outra pessoa não faz a nossa
dor diminuir de modo nenhum a gente vai
produzir mais dor e mais sofrimento e
não vai conseguir diminuir na ferida que
nós que nós tenhamos então a justiça
restaurativa no tempo
explorando elas se propõem exatamente a
devolver as vítimas esse protagonismo na
na resolução de seus seus conflitos das
suas dores e perceber que o ajuste o
sistema de justiça penal ele nos engana
cotidianamente é uma fraude ea mídia
contribui decisivamente para isso porque
pedimos e e allen cita a sociedade
acreditar que mais punição que redução
da idade penal que mais violência que
mais prisões seria sempre o caminho pra
gente viver numa sociedade mais justa e
quanto mais sistema penal nós temos mais
injusta é uma sociedade nas sociedades
mais justas do mundo são aquelas que têm
menos pessoas presas encarceram - e que
os índices de qualidade são os mais
razoáveis mas são uns a violência
inominável a violência é um componente
da nossa existência
nós não eliminarmos jamais a violência
violência faz parte de nós ela está em
nós mas tem uma justiça penal
ele é um mecanismo absolutamente
degradante humilhante de produção de
muito mais dor e sofrimento do que a
violência que ele deseja combater
muito obrigado